Cutting Edge effects technology isn't
always used to create cool explosions in
giant robots released nearly 30 years
after the original film Tron legacy is a
computerized Adventure packed with light
cycles and Daft Punk music most
importantly this 2010 Disney film gave
audiences double the dude Jeff Bridges
returned to the Tron universe as two
separate characters first there's the
heroic Kevin Flynn who looks exactly
like the older actor but then there's
clue the artificial intelligence gone
Rogue and while he was played by a man
in his 60s this evil computer program
looks more or less like Bridges did back
in the 80s VFX supervisor Eric Barba
oversaw the transformation he achieved
it with a four camera head-mounted
system that Bridges wore on the set to
get a floating 3D Point cloud of his
face the effect may look a little
computery but that's okay because after
all clue is a computer program the
tragic death of Paul Walker in 2013 sent
a massive shock wave through the Fast
and Furious Community after all this is
a franchise about family and both Walker
and his character of Brian O'Connor were
super important to a whole lot of people
his death had serious implications for
the production of Furious 7 as the actor
died during filming fortunately wedded
digital was able to save the day and
preserve Walker's Legacy for Fast and
Furious fans around the world the folks
at wedda digitally created a whopping
350 shots of Walker doing everything
from jumping skyscrapers to standing in
a lineup with the rest of his crew
additionally Walker's brothers Caleb and
Cody and actor John Brotherton gave
motion capture performances that wetta
used to recreate Brian thanks to their
incredible work he got to ride with his
family one last time when Kevin Spacey
was accused by multiple victims of
sexual assault director Ridley Scott
made one of the gutsiest decisions in
Hollywood history Spacey and Scott had
recently finished working on all the
money in the world when the Scandal
broke unwilling to keep Spacey in the
film Scott replaced the actor with
Christopher Plummer reshooting every
scene featuring Spacey's character
stingy billionaire J Paul Getty it was
an unprecedented move and it cost 10
million dollars to exercise Spacey from
the film most of these scenes were done
practically with other actors on actual
sets but there is one quick moment in
which Scott resorted to some digital
trickery for a scene in which Getty goes
to Jordan it was too impractical to go
all the way back to the Middle East so
Plummer was shot in front of a green
screen and after the special effects
crew digitally erased Spacey they just
slid Plummer right into place
2017's Blade Runner 2049 was a beautiful
follow-up to the original 1982 Blade
Runner it saw the return of Harrison
Ford as Rick Deckard but he wasn't the
only original cast member to come back
during one key scene the Aging Deckard
is confronted by a ghost from his past
it's Rachel the replicant he fell in
love with in the first film only this
isn't the Rachel that Deckard remembers
that Rachel is dead this is a new shiny
one created solely to tempt Deckard to
the dark side and this isn't exactly the
actress we remember either in order to
DH Sean Young by over 30 years the
moving pitcher company analyzed photos
of her studied scenes from the first
film and even checked out Young's other
performances from around the same era
they also photographed young with a
special device that captured her
likeness from multiple angles with all
these references they were able to
create a CGI face that they could then
layer onto a body double who shot the
scene with Ford with young standing by
as an advisor unlike many digital
Creations the Rachel of 2049 looks
incredibly lifelike which is kinda
perfect for a movie that wonders what
makes us human in this film about adult
friends playing a game of tag for years
and years Jeremy Renner is an
uncatchable man he's been evading his
buddies by moving like an Olympic
Athlete and dodging outstretched hands
like he's in The Matrix during one of
these Escape scenes Renner jumped on top
of a huge stack of chairs which resulted
in disaster when the rigging that held
the chairs in place snapped and sent him
tumbling when Renner got up he realized
he'd broken both his arms as he
explained to Entertainment Weekly he
could still move his limbs up and down
kind of like a robot so he didn't need
too much digital assistance however
there is one moment when the VFX crew
had to create a completely CG arm and
it's in the very scene where his stunt
went wrong specifically when he tosses a
donut at Ed Helms needless to say we're
legitimately impressed that Renner could
deal with all that pain and continue
filming
whenever you see a nude scene in a movie
there's a good chance that nobody on set
ever really got naked often actors wear
flesh-colored underwear and for most
movies this is enough because intimate
scenes don't really factor into the plot
not true for the film adaptation of 50
Shades of Gray those scenes are the plot
which posed a unique problem for the
effects Department specifically because
it showed more skin than most other
films do a decision needed to be made
about whether or not Dakota Johnson's
character Anastasia Steele had a
personal grooming routine apparently she
didn't because a digital effects artist
had to go in during post-production and
use CGI to give Johnson
um one of these cinematographer Sheamus
McGarvey would later refer to this as
one of the most surreal moments of his
entire career closely followed by
overseeing the hiring process of a
suitable butt double for Johnson
it's safe to say that Nicholas Cage
loves comic books his son Cal L is named
after Superman he changed his own last
name early in his career from Coppola to
cage as a nod to Marvel character Luke
Cage and he even has a large tattoo of
the Ghost Rider on his arm this latter
tribute proved to be a problem when cage
was set to star in the 2007 Ghost Writer
film because well it would have been
kind of weird for Johnny Blaze to have a
tattoo of his own superhero Alter Ego on
his bicep so the decision was made to
use the magic of special effects to hide
the offending tattoo whenever cage
needed to take off his shirt a
persistent rumor surrounding the movie
suggests that Cage's ABS were also
created using the magic of CGI however
his Ghost Writer co-star Ava Mendes has
confirmed they were in fact 100 real
[Music]
oh
there's a scene in the first season of
Game of Thrones when the character Hodor
played by actor Christian Narin gets
naked revealing the giant characters
suitably plus-sized Anatomy to achieve
the illusion neren was asked to wear a
realistic looking
16-inch prosthetic that was attached to
his groin using glue
so for weeks later I'll be finding
pieces of prosthetic penis attached to
my own the effects Department then
Blended the whole thing to his body
using digital effects air brushing out a
special thong niren was wearing beneath
the whole getup according to the actor
this thong shielded his actual package
from view so well that one of his
co-stars asked if it was real there's
only one response to that question
hold on
if you happen to catch peewee's big
holiday on Netflix you may have noticed
that after Paul Rubens looked
surprisingly spry and Youthful for a
60-something year old man to give the
impression that Rubens hadn't aged since
his last TV appearance as the character
CGI was used in tandem with makeup
lighting and sticky tape to de-age the
actor and that last part isn't a joke
tape was used to pull back Ruben's face
for some scenes to make his skin look
smoother sometimes the simplest
Solutions are the best ones to his
credit Rubens was surprisingly open
about the use of CGI to remove his
wrinkles admitting that Peewee simply
wouldn't work with age mixed into it
This Bar Stone French toast American
toast the hit musical dramedy Glee
continued the long-standing Hollywood
tradition of hiring older actors to play
Teenagers although none of the actors
playing high schoolers on the show were
the age they were supposed to be they
still apparently suffered from a fairly
common Affliction that plagues all young
people acne this didn't sit well with
the producers who paid an unnamed visual
effects company to do what was dubbed a
pimple pass on most episodes to ensure
every actor's skin was blemish free
because if there's anything that's going
to make a show relatable to young people
it's Flawless looking actors with
Perfect Skin complaining about being
unattractive
Jessica Alba resolved long ago did not
take off her clothes for a movie she
told Scarlet magazine in 2010 I can act
sexy and wear sexy clothes but I can't
go naked my grandmother would freak out
and throw a towel over me if she saw me
wearing just a bra and panties I can
handle being sexy with clothes on but
not with them off anyone who watched
2010's machete after reading the article
in Scarlet was likely surprised when
Alba appeared to be nude during a shower
scene but the key word there is appeared
in reality Alba was clothed and her
garments were digitally replaced in
post-production with computer generated
skin
when a regular for a hit show gets
pregnant sometimes creators use the
tools the universe has given them and
write the pregnancy into the story
but when Claire Danes announced she was
pregnant with her first child in 2012
she assured fans her Homeland character
Carrie Matheson would remain fervently
non-pregnant for the show's second
season Dane's onset work for season two
of Homeland continued as late as six
weeks before she gave birth her baby
bump was digitally erased in
post-production and body doubles were
also used to help with the subterfuge it
wouldn't be the last time Homeland used
these strategies to keep a pregnancy out
of the story the following year they
used similar techniques on Morena
Baccarin even though it didn't show up
on screen Dane's pregnancy didn't make
things any easier for her she described
one particularly difficult scene that
had her chained in a basement it was 4
am I was seven and a half months
pregnant and I was like this
sucks she also said the pregnancy made
love scenes difficult using the example
of the shooting of one love scene when
her baby was particularly active it was
like he was protesting on my husband's
behalf among all the other worldly
characters in Marvel movies the young
scrawny Steve Rogers in 2011's Captain
America the First Adventure remains one
of Marvel's most impressive CGI effects
no single technique was used to create
these smaller and skinnier
pre-experiment Steve Rogers Marvel hired
Lola visual effects to do the digital
Bodywork on Chris Evans for Captain
America Lola's supervisor Edson Williams
told variety that the so-called Benjamin
Button method or digitally attaching
evans's face to a body double was only
used for 15 of the shots for the rest
Lola digitally shrunk Evan's face and
body the process involved shooting
everything at least three times once
with Evans once with Evan's smaller body
double and one clean shot without either
of them with each shot the team
determined whether to go the easier
Benjamin Button route or what Lola Came
to call Steve slimming Williams said the
most challenging part of the process was
caused by Evan's massive arms when shot
in profile they blocked an entire third
of his body so the fabric of Evan's
shirts would need to be digitally erased
and replaced with something else to give
the illusion of skinny and comparatively
weak arms that's probably the only time
in the history of superhero movies that
bulking up turned out to be a bad thing
For Better or Worse prequels are now a
staple of film franchises and CGI is
part of what makes them possible the
filmmakers of Rogue one faced
particularly tough challenges for the
story they wanted they needed to
recreate the characters of Grandma
Tarkin and Princess Leia Peter Cushing
who played Tarkin in 1977's Star Wars
passed away in 1994. Carrie Fisher who
portrayed Princess Leia was still alive
during the making of Rogue one but she
looked and sounded nothing like she had
since about four decades had passed so
Tarkin and Leia were digitally recreated
for principal photography Tarkin was
played by British actor guy Henry who
wore a motion capture headpiece during
filming animators worked meticulously to
recreate the actor's mannerisms not
quite so much work was needed for the
digital Rebirth of Princess Leia when
seen from behind she's fully Norwegian
actress ingvilde dala from the front
what you see is almost entirely a
digital creation though Leia's
outstretched hand is stalas
X-Men the Last Stand is not a well-loved
movie among comic book fans but at least
one aspect of the film was pretty
groundbreaking the film opens with
Professor X and Magneto making an early
attempt to recruit Jean Gray into
Xavier's School for mutants the
flashback sequence takes place around 20
years before the events of the rest of
the film and the filmmaker is one of the
actors appearances to reflect those
younger days rather than using
Prosthetics or special motion capture
suits the sequence was shot as if no
changes were going to be made to it at
all the VFX team then used a process
called digital skin grafting to
rejuvenate Stuart and McKellen utilizing
old photographs for reference as well as
Consulting with a plastic surgeon to
learn the specifics of how skin changes
as people age
like the film that preceded it Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 opens on Earth
several decades in the past we see
Meredith quill being romanced by a Kurt
Russell who looks like he could have
just finished filming Big Trouble in
Little China but there seems to be a
little disagreement regarding how this
on-screen Rejuvenation was achieved when
Russell talked about the transformation
he said it was about 90 makeup and added
that the filmmakers didn't do much
digital manipulation Russell says he's
been working with the same makeup artist
Dennis Ledger since 1989 and Ledger
pulled off most of the work they just
did a little brush up clean up on a
couple of things but it's pretty much
what Dennis Ledger did writer slash
director James Gunn's recollection is
significantly different in the comments
section of a video gun posted on
Facebook the director responded to a fan
question about the flashback sequence he
wrote a company named Lola did the
effects and they did an incredible job
first we film every scene with Kurt a
young actor Aaron Schwartz watches
everything Kurt Russell does he then
goes in and mimics Kurt's actions we
then take Kurt's acting in general face
and body and place Aaron's skin onto him
it is a long painstaking process that
took many many months to accomplish
for all the CGI used in Captain America
Civil War the film's most stunning
visual effect came in a comparatively
low-key moment an early scene in Civil
War opens to what appears to be a
flashback a young Tony Stark is giving
exactly the snark we expect from him as
his parents Howard and Maria are about
to leave for a fateful trip he was the
homeless person on the couch
this is why I love coming home for
Christmas right before you leave town we
eventually learned we're seeing Stark's
memories as they're translated through a
device Stark has developed as they did
when digitally rejuvenating characters
in earlier films Marvel Studios called
on Lola visual effects to take 20 to 25
years off Downing the scene presented
one of the toughest challenges Lola has
had to tackle while working with Marvel
because the entire sequence was filmed
in a single shot Trent Klaus Lola's
visual effects supervisor told The
Hollywood Reporter the shot was nearly 4
000 frames long with Tony Stark turning
from one side to the other multiple
times physically interacting with other
actors and the set itself and moving
closer to the camera for a very long
uninterrupted close-up Klaus went on to
say that analyzing footage from Downey's
late 80s film work was essential in
achieving the effect and singled out
1987's less than zero as a focal point
it freaked everything I freaked me the
heck out you know I was like my God he
was beautiful full
gal gadot's Wonder Woman has received
her fair share of CGI assistance the
israeli-born actor isn't capable of
deflecting bullets or chucking tanks in
real life so she needs a little help to
make her character a bit more believable
however the biggest job for the effects
Department was to hide the Miracle of
Life during the reshoots for Patty
Jenkins first Wonder Woman film Cadet
revealed to Entertainment Weekly that
she was five months pregnant with her
daughter Maya when she was required to
head back to the set for additional
filming due to her growing baby bump the
filmmakers had to find a way to work
around it since a pregnancy wasn't a
part of the storyline so the costume
designers cut a gap in her costume
around the belly area and placed a green
cloth there that allowed the effects
team to manipulate the visuals at a
later stage speaking about the
experience the Dutch said on close-up I
looked very much like Wonder Woman on
wide shots I looked very funny like
Wonder Woman pregnant with Kermit the
Frog the they cut a big triangle and
painted green and I came to work me and
Maya we came to work together Martin
Scorsese the Irishman is an ambitious
film not only because it has to keep the
audience's attention for almost four
hours but also because it spans five
decades during its run time while an
easier approach might have been to cast
new actors for each specific era of the
story Scorsese wanted his main cast to
be present throughout senior actor and
Irishman star Robert De Niro also made
it abundantly clear that he wasn't going
to wear green dots or motion capture
suits to make it happen according to the
Los Angeles Times
I was just doing a job to make some
extra money
industrial Light and Magic took on the
challenge of creating new technology to
tell the Epic Story the team created a
new camera rig for Scorsese to use on
set which would pick up the kind of data
that would be transmitted through the
tracking dots normally then they would
edit the shots in granular detail
including the frown and smile lines of
characters such as De Niro's Frank
Sheeran however practical effects played
a major part as well wigs and
Prosthetics were utilized to add to the
authenticity
the Star Wars timeline is a lot like
flipping through family photo albums not
everything is in sequential order the
stories jump around from era to era as
filmmakers and showrunners cherry pick
moments in fictional history in which
they will set their tails this creates a
little problem actors are human and
humans age no matter how good the
sunscreen and skin care products they
use are an actor who was 25 3 decades
ago will look significantly older in
modern times solo a Star Wars story
solved this challenge by casting a
younger actor Alden ehrenreich as Han
Solo but the Mandalorian simply had to
have Mark Hamill return as Luke
Skywalker we knew we wanted Mark Hamill
front and center because you can't bring
back Luke Skywalker without Mark Hamill
in an interview with Indie wire
industrial Light and Magic VFX
supervisor Richard Bluff explained how
the team approached de-aging Hamill
while trying to capture the same look as
from Return of the Jedi Hamel appeared
on set in costume and performed the
required actions but there was a younger
body double Max Lloyd Jones who was
responsible for many of the sequences as
well essentially the VFX crew deep fake
tamil's face onto Lloyd Jones for the
close-up scenes
Toby Maguire knows all about the power
of CGI having starred in the original
Spider-Man trilogy however it isn't his
time as Spidey that gives him a spot on
this list it's his appearance as the
nameless hitchhiker in Terry gilliam's
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas now why
would the hitchhiker of all people in
this film require any type of digital
assistance some may ask well the answer
involves something green but not the
kind that's placed on actors and
backgrounds for VFX no the reason for
this special effect was cold Hard Cash
according to geek Maguire shaved off all
his hair so the production could get the
unique aesthetic for his character and
ended up being called back for reshoots
a while later reportedly Maguire had a
special clause in his contract that
stated he would be paid an extra fifteen
thousand dollars if he needed to shave
his head again the filmmakers decided to
save some cash so they stuck a bald cap
on him and tried to digitally match the
hair with the previous footage most of
us have to pay to get our hair cut but
McGuire was lucky enough to have it the
other way around
Marvel Studios is no stranger to
de-aging actors but making Samuel L
Jackson's Nick Fury look 25 years
younger was a daunting task previously a
digitally edited character would appear
for no more than a few shots but Fury
was a fundamental part of the storyline
who appeared in a good number of scenes
no corners could be cut fortunately
there was no need for new technologies
or inventions as Lola visual effects
felt comfortable enough with the task at
hand Marvel VFX supervisor Christopher
Townsend explained to the rep that the
team looked at films that Jackson
starred in in the 90s like Jurassic Park
to build their digital version of the
younger Fury but I do know that they
referenced some films that I did from
that time so when I look at it I see you
know Danny Roman's face from negotiating
Jackson's graceful age
challenge to the team Lola VFX
supervisor Trent Claus elaborated if
you're working with someone like Sam who
really doesn't have a whole lot of
wrinkles you really have to rely on
physiological changes changes in
structure of musculature textures of
skin the way the weight hangs on your
neck and your jaw things over time like
that we've studied for so many years now
Dwayne The Rock Johnson may look like a
character from Street Fighter in the
flesh but he puts a lot of hard work
into looking good on the screen and
being the most electrifying man in
Hollywood however there is a moment in
The Comedy Central Intelligence where
Johnson plays a teenage version of his
character dancing in the nude and not
looking quite as shredded as he is in
the real world no we're not gonna go
this man insulted you and we're not
gonna leave until he apologizes so it's
okay hey we got a problem here no no the
team behind this transformation was the
celebrated what a FX the new
zealand-based special effects company
used some smart techniques to make this
scene look as authentic as possible and
not too jarring to the viewer according
to wired wetta got popular vine
personality sioni kalippi to dance while
they captured his performance and
specific gestures then they brought in
Johnson and kalebi to do detailed facial
scans with which they were able to match
their expressions and combine multiple
performances into a single character
oh my
birthdays
how you doing
since El Camino a Breaking Bad movie is
a sequel to Breaking Bad that follows
Jesse Pinkman not many people expected
Brian cranston's Walter White to appear
considering the fate of his character at
the end of the series however the film
does a good job of exploring the future
and past so Walter indeed makes an
appearance by sitting down with Jesse in
a diner scene while Cranston never had a
problem shaving his head to play Walter
on the series he did have a problem when
El Camino came around he was performing
on Broadway and couldn't take a razor to
his hair the solution seemed easy enough
a bald cap unfortunately it didn't look
as convincing to the filmmakers as they
had hoped for in the end the digital
effects team had to take the digital
brush to Walter's head to fix any issues
with the bald cap per The Hollywood
Reporter for such a simple and
unassuming scene most of it had to be
recreated with visual effects
[Music]